men and women of the capitol police for
the work that they do every single day
tomorrow
marks one year
since a violent mob staged an
insurrection
in an attempt to disrupt the peaceful
transition of power while congress was
gathered to certify the results of the
2020 presidential election
that mob desecrated our capital the
temple of our democracy and delayed the
counting of the electoral votes
but thanks to the heroism of the people
that work with you chief
thanks to our brave law enforcement
officers we were able to finish our work
i will never forget walking down to the
house chamber from the senate floor
with my friend senator blunt and vice
president pence it was 3 30 a.m
3 30 a.m and we walked through that
hallway broken glass
on the sides
spray paint on the statues remembering
that just that day earlier we had done
this joyful walk
for the
what is every four years the peaceful
transition to power no matter who wins
democrat or republican and there we were
alone in that hallway with two young
women holding the mahogany box that had
the last remaining electoral ballots up
to the state
of wyoming
and while it was a sorrowful day
and you lost
officers and we had so many people
injured i had this moment as thinking as
we walked down that hallway in the end
because of the bravery of your
officers
democracy prevailed
many of us remember that insurrection
for what it was an attack on our
democracy
but it was also as we'll talk about
today a brutal and prolonged physical
attack for the law enforcement officers
who risked their lives to defend the
capital that day
tragically five officers who reported
for duty
have since passed away including capitol
police officer brian sicknick who died
the day after the attack four other
officers died in the days and months
that followed capitol police officer
howard liebengood
dc metropolitan police officers jeffrey
smith
gunther hishida
and kyle defrytag and of course we all
remember
billy evans who died in an incident
unrelated to this attack
many more suffered physical injuries and
even more sustained emotional trauma
from the events of that day
we owe it to the capitol police officers
who defend the capitol every day to make
sure that they have the resources and
support they need to do their jobs
that's why in the immediate aftermath of
the attack this committee
convened a series of hearings senator
blunt and i on a bipartisan basis with
every single member of this committee
involved democrat and republican joined
forces with the homeland security
committee and held these hearings out of
that came a bipartisan report that
senator blunt and senator peters and
portman and i authored with findings and
20 recommendations for agencies across
the federal government to be implemented
without delay
as we approach the solemn anniversary
today we will hear i know because i've
read your testimony that significant
progress has been made to implement
the recommendations that pertain to the
capitol police and i thank you and all
your officers for that
the changes made since january 6 of
course started at the top
we said the capitol police board must
appoint a new police chief and they
selected you in july we also have two
new sergeant-at-arms in the senate
leader schumer appointed general karen
gibson who just finished a term as board
chair and who has worked to put
recommendations in place
in the house speaker pelosi appointed
general william walker who led the d.c
national guard on january 6 and in fact
has testified before this committee in
that role
as i note on january 6 we saw 75 percent
of officers on duty forced to defend the
capital in their regular uniforms in
plain clothes
in some cases they had less protective
gear than the insurrectionists
themselves
that's why we recommended that the
capitol police have enough officers with
appropriate training and equipment and
in july as i note president biden signed
emergency funding legislation led in the
senate by chairman leahy to deliver
resources to do exactly that
we also saw the former police chief that
day delayed for over an hour trying to
get approval to call in the national
guard in an absurd situation he was
trying to reach the sergeant-at-arms in
order to follow the law who in fact were
trying to defend their own chambers at a
time when shots had been fired and
people had been killed
senator blunt and i
introduced a bill
along with a number of other members of
this community including senators king
wicker feinstein capital merkley padilla
and warner and it was signed into law
that this month to make it easier for
you chief to call in the national guard
if ever such an emergency situation
would arise again
we will never forget
also the haunting words of an officer
desperately calling over the radio that
day in the middle of the insurrection
does anyone have a plan
does anyone have a plan
the answer sadly that day was no so we
recommended that the capitol police
produce a department-wide operational
plan for all large-scale events at the
capitol and that is now standard
procedure
no will never be the answer again
we also heard how officers on the front
lines were left without critical
information we said the department
needed to take significant action to
improve its handling of intelligence and
it has worked to ensure information is
shared with rank and file officers
so while there is so much to do
including as we know hiring multiple
additional officers and i'm sure you'll
be asked about that today as well as
making sure the department is equipped
to respond to the dramatic increase in
threats against members of congress
which have now exceeded uh by your
reports over 9 000 in the last year more
than we have ever seen double triple
what we have seen completely related
to what we saw on january 6th
and that of course is a challenge for
your department to respond to
to close i will note that while today we
will discuss the steps that have been
taken and the work that lies ahead to
ensure the security of our nation's
capital there must also be more done to
safeguard the future of our very
democracy
i continue to support the work of the
house select committee to bring the
underlying causes of the insurrection to
light to hold people accountable for
what happened
and it is crucial as ever in addition to
that that we pass legislation to protect
the freedom to vote in the senate
because at this moment
we are dealing with a slew of laws that
have either been introduced or passed
around the country major overhauls to
legislation that make it harder for
people to vote
it is if what wasn't accomplished with
bear spray or bayonet is now being
attempted to be accomplished through
laws that limit voting on weekends laws
that limit ballot drop boxes to one in a
major city
laws that literally disband
non-partisan voting boards to be
replaced by partisan counting of the
votes
that's what we're seeing across the
country right now it is not the subject
of this hearing but it is clearly
related to what happened on january 6.
with that we look forward to hearing
from you chief major about the progress
you have made and the work still to be
done and now i will turn it over to my
good friend senator roy blunt and i
thank him again on a bipartisan basis
for working through and this entire
committee what we needed to do to make
the security recommendations for changes
the funding for changes the legal change
the legal provisions for changes
as well as the respect and dignity that
your officers deserved and deserve every
day thank you senator blunt
thank you senator klobuchar i know that
senator schumer is on a tight schedule
this morning
are you sure
well thank you senator klobuchar i'm
glad to be here today and i'm glad
we have the chance to thank
chief manger for joining us and for the
leadership he's already provided to the
capitol to police the
january 6 attack on the u.s capitol was
a tragic day for our country
everyone who took part in that that
attack should be prosecuted based on
their actions and plans
that process continues and i support it
as we approach today's one-year
anniversary of the attack it's important
we keep the capitol police officers
and those from other responding agencies
including the d.c metropolitan police
who were here within minutes and made an
incredible difference in the ability to
respond
along with the national guard federal
law enforcement and others who we really
need to keep in the front of our minds
as we have this discussion uh today with
the chief you know the u.s capitol is
our most iconic symbol of democracy
the whole world was watching to see how
we responded to the attack
these officers were the true heroes of
january 6. they defended the capital and
everyone who works here bravely and
without hesitation
thanks to their efforts senator
klobuchar just pointed out we were able
to return to the senate and house
chambers and finish our work we're able
to show the world that when our system
is tested
it will prevail
my colleagues and i are profoundly
grateful for the capitol police
continued dedication to the mission to
protect the congress
it's our job to honor their service by
doing our part to ensure
that they are never faced with the
circumstances they were faced with that
day the committee's held a number of
hearings with respect to the events of
january 6. this is the fifth of those
hearings
throughout those hearings and in our
subsequent actions chairman klobuchar
and i are proud of the bipartisan
way that we've been able to move forward
to show that
we want to ensure that capitol police
have the resources necessary to protect
both the congress and the agency's most
valuable asset the officers themselves
senator klobuchar and i introduced
legislation with many of our colleagues
on this committee which passed both the
house and senate by unanimous consent
and was signed into law by the president
on december the 22nd this legislation
the capitol police emergency assistance
act of 2021
provides the capitol police chief with
unilateral authority to request
emergency assistance from the national
guard and other federal law enforcement
agencies in emergencies
as i previously mentioned we held a
number of hearings on this subject and
released a bipartisan report
with homeland security and the
government affairs committee
in june of
2021 which outlined several
recommendations based on extensive
interviews with key decision makers
firsthand account from law enforcement
personnel
and review of thousands of documents
we've continued to pursue more
information on this issue we've also
worked with our colleagues on the
emergency security supplemental
appropriations act of 2021 to provide
the department with additional
and necessary funding for salaries
overtime pay
trauma support
riot control equipment for all officers
in specialized training
certainly chairman leahy's leadership on
that piece of legislation along with
senator shelby
made a big difference in quickly
responding to what was the immediate
need of the department after the
increased workload and the stress of
what happened a year ago
beyond the work of congress the capitol
police have been reviewing operations
and looking at necessary changes within
the department
we tried twice heard from the inspector
general including last month as he
concluded his 11th 11-month
investigation
in the department's preparations for and
response to
the events of january 6th
i appreciate today's opportunity to hear
from chief manger
in the
on the security enhancements the
department has made over the past year
the work being done to improve officer
morale and retention as well as the
chief's observations after six months
in command and his goals and visions for
the department moving forward
one year after january 6 2021 we
acknowledge that there have been cons
there's been considerable progress but
also
acknowledged as i'm sure the chief does
from his comments today that much work
remains to be done
we'll continue to work together to
ensure the department addresses its
critical needs
and is positioned to be better trained
better equipped and better prepared in
the future
we owe that to the front line uscp
officers who protect members of congress
congressional officers
employees and visitors to the capitol
every day
we also by the way owe that to their
families
chief menger
uh thank you for being here with us
today i look forward to hearing from you
from you as you reflect on the changes
the department has made
over the past year uh and what work
remains to be done uh thank you chair
thank you very much uh now thank you
senator schumer and when you were uh i
know you were busy with something else
senator schumer but i did mention um
that your leadership in making sure we
got a sergeant-at-arms in place who's
doing a very good job so thank you for
that um and thank you for your
leadership thank you well thank you and
let me thank the chair of the rules
committee my good friend senator
klobuchar
uh for the great work she has done in
this regard um in making our capital
much safer and let me uh thank my friend
the ranking member for his bipartisan
cooperation on this important issue
um
and i thank you for the opportunity to
speak right now
i also want to thank today's witness u.s
capitol chief of police thomas manger
2021 was one of the hardest years ever
for our capitol police
but chief manger has done an outstanding
job in his first few months ushering a
necessary reforms to the department
he'll be the first to say the job is not
done
but today the capitol is a whole lot
safer than it was a year ago and i
commend him for his leadership i feel
safe walking around the halls of this
this hallowed building
my colleagues
were here today
because one year ago
the men and women of our capitol police
stood on the front lines of the
unthinkable unthinkable in america
a violent assault upon the u.s capitol
instigated by former president trump and
carried out by a mob of radicals looking
to halt the peaceful transfer of power
i remember january 6 as if it were
yesterday
i've said repeatedly over the last year
my experience that day was sort of like
charles dickens a tale of two cities
it was the best of times it was the
worst of times the best of times
because at 4 00 a.m that morning
we had learned those of us on the
democratic side anyway that senators
warnock and our ossoff had won
and we would come back into the majority
i couldn't sleep got in my car at 7 30
got here at 12 30 got on the floor of
the senate at 1 p.m as we began to count
the votes
i was only on the floor of the senate
for about an hour as the putative
majority leader not even having given a
speech when a police officer in a
bulletproof vest and with a submachine
gun strapped across his waist grabbed me
firmly by the collar like this i'll
never forget that grip he said senator
we're in danger we got to get out of
here here to explain to me what the
danger was i didn't know none of us knew
at that time
we walked through a hallway went through
a door
and this was shown on the video camera
that was captured and they used it at
the impeachment trial i hadn't seen it
until they did it then but they show me
walking briskly with police officer on
either side down a hallway we go through
a door you don't see us for 20 seconds
and then we're running out at full speed
i was within 30 feet of these nasty
insurrectionists
had one of them had a gun
had two of them blocked off the door
lord knows what would have happened
so that was quite a day and it was even
a tougher day much tougher for our
capitol hill policemen
they were outnumbered they were
under-equipped
yet their bravery their quick thinking
saved many lives and prevented a violent
riot from becoming something even worse
it allowed us when the four leaders met
and decided we were going to not let
these insurrectionists stop us
from going forward with the counting of
the ballots it allowed us to come back
that night at 8 pm
and actually finish the counting
having the insurrectionists object that
day to stop the count fail
so today we honor those who stepped up
that day and especially those whom we've
lost in the aftermath
we remember them
and pray for their families
now since in the years since that attack
as has been mentioned we've gotten a lot
done in the senate to strengthen our
capitol police
to assure
from a security standpoint that the
violence of that day never happens again
early last year i put in place a new
sergeant-at-arms lieutenant general
karen gibson a wonderfully competent
person with a great deal of experience
on both the organizational uh side
as well as on the intelligence side and
we installed the first all-women
leadership team
in the history of the senate
sergeant-at-arms
as a member of the capitol police board
ms gibson led a diligent search and
helped us find the new police chief who
sits here today
it was so important to me
that we had a new police chief
who was competent experienced and
dedicated
i am proud that we have found such an
individual in j thomas manger
last summer we did a few other things we
passed a critical supplemental funding
led by senator leahy
and senator shelby providing tens of
millions in overtime pay funding for
more police officers hazard pay and
retention of bonuses for the capitol
police
and just last month we passed
legislation authorizing the chief
to summon the national guard in future
emergencies without prior authorization
we all know what we went through that
day
trying to get the national guard to come
quickly
thanks to his work the chief's work and
the new leadership of the capitol police
the u.s today is much safer than it was
a year ago although we're continuing to
work on that vital job of the safety of
this capital
but let's be clear let's be very clear
january 6 was not a mere not merely a
census act of mob violence that sprung
up spontaneously
it was an attempt to reverse
through violent means
the outcome of a free and fair election
and make no mistake
the root cause of january 6th is still
with us today
it is the big lie
pushed by donald trump
that is undermining faith in our
political system
and making our democracy our country
less safe
the biggest threat to our capital our
capital police and our democracy
is the insinious insidious motives
stemming from the big lie
propagated by the former president
and many of his republican allies across
the country
we can and we will continue to make sure
the capital is safe from a security
point standpoint
but without addressing the root causes
of the violence
on
on january 6
the insurrection will not be an
aberration
it could well become the norm
and just like the senate has the power
to pass legislation supporting our
capitol police force
we have the same power and obligation
to pass legislation to address these
root causes that brought the big lie
to life
that is what my senate democratic
colleagues and i are focused on and
committed to doing
here in the rules committee and among
our caucus as a whole
and we must act we must act
more than at any point in recent history
threats of political violence are on the
rise
election administrators
basically people who are almost like
civil servants
just
trying to count the elections accurately
are facing harassment even death threats
for carrying out their duty isn't that a
sad day in this country
when the people
who in many situations and non-partisan
in many situations bipartisan but are
simply dedicated to counting the vote
fairly are threatened
something is very wrong
by one measure
nearly a third of those who count the
votes
say they feel less safe on the job
and many many many of them are quitting
because they fear for their safety what
has this country come to when that
happens
when the wellspring of our democracy
the fair unbiased counting of the votes
which has been part of our hallmark in
this country
since we've started
which is the root of democracy
when that is when people who do that are
threatened with violence
what has come of our country
so we must act we must act
my colleagues
the threats that i have mentioned are
the symptoms of an illness
festering deep within the bones of our
democracy and unless we confront the big
lie
unless all of us do our part to fortify
and strengthen our democracy
the political violence of january 6th
risks
becoming little more than a taste of
dangers to come
all of us have a role to play
to protect our democratic system
everyone from our capitol police to the
voting public to those of us entrusted
to serve in elected office
and again
just as the capitol police have taken
the experience of january 6
to institute reforms for the future
every member of the united states senate
is called on to do the same
to reckon with the lessons of that
terrible day
and to take action to cure america of
the disease
of the big lie
that means passing legislation to
protect our democracy from subversion
and safeguard the right to vote
including the john lewis voting rights
advancement act and the freedom to vote
act
in the weeks to come i look forward to
working with all my colleagues to
achieve this goal
for now let me close again by thanking
chief manger for being here
and for leading his department in making
the changes necessary to prepare for the
future
let me thank senator klobuchar senator
senator blunt and the rules committee
for their role i know it's not easy work
i know at times it's been met with
resistance
but i commend you captain
for keeping your eye on the big picture
and for doing your part to protect our
democracy it is my hope
the senate can follow suit in the near
future
thank you very much uh leader schumer
well said um i will now introduce our
witness uh mr thomas manger the chief of
the united states capitol police
that chief major was sworn into his
current position on july 21st 2021 he
joined the department following a
distinguished 42-year career in law
enforcement
most recently serving for 15 years as
chief of police in montgomery county
maryland
during that time he was also elected by
his peers across the country to serve as
the president of the major city chiefs
association
earlier in his career he served as chief
of police in fairfax county virginia
where he rose through the ranks after
first joining the force following his
graduation from the university of
maryland i will now swear in our witness
chief major if you could please stand
and raise your right hand
do you swear that the testimony you will
give before the committee shall be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you god
thank you you can be seated you're now
recognized for five minutes
chairwoman klobuchar
ranking member blunt distinguished
members of the committee thank you for
providing me with the opportunity to
speak about the significant improvements
that we've made following the events of
january 6th and to speak about the work
that remains to be done
i want to begin by acknowledging the men
and women of the capitol police who work
so tirelessly to fulfill their mission
of protecting the us capital
the members of congress and the
legislative process every day it's my
honor to work with these women and men
who performed so courageously a year ago
and while i'm proud of our officers the
events of january 6th did expose
critical departmental failures and
deficiencies with operational planning
intelligence staffing training and
equipment i'm pleased to report that we
have addressed a significant portion of
the many recommendations issued to the
department in fact of the more than 100
recommendations issued by the inspector
general we have implemented and are
addressing
over 90 of them the staff report issued
by your committee listed five
recommendations directed to the united
states capitol police i can tell you
that the department has implemented or
is in the process of implementing each
one of them
i'm prepared to discuss many of the
recommendations today but understanding
the time limitations i'll focus on the
improvements that are the most impactful
and that address the core of the
committee's findings and conclusions
i've provided under separate cover for
inclusion in the official hearing record
a more complete formal statement that
includes a detailed list of all the
department's post-january 6th
improvements
the committee concluded that an
important contributing factor to the
breach of the capital was the lack of a
department-wide operational plan for the
joint session
an important first step we took to
address that concern was the onboarding
of a former secret service official with
extensive experience in major event and
national special security event planning
guided by his expertise we now take a
multi-faced approach
to our planning
to our planning process
with a focus on information gathering
intelligence asset determination
internal coordination and most
importantly department-wide
dissemination of all intelligence and
critical information before all large
and high-risk events
this also includes the creation of the
department's first critical incident
response plan which now allows us to
more effectively and more quickly obtain
assistance from partner agencies in
short a blueprint for operational
planning has been created and put into
place for all future significant events
if january 6 taught us anything it's
that preparation matters
immediately after the sixth the
department focused on the need to
strengthen our front-line officers the
civil disturbance unit or cdu
for any demonstration that involves
violence or the potential for violence
the need for a well-trained and
well-equipped cdu is crucial
recognizing the tactical importance of
our cdu officers we've developed a plan
to elevate their status and incentivize
them to remain in the unit the plan
entails the creation of eight
hard platoons
these platoons will be permanent units
whose members train together and are
deployed together
we've done other things as well to
strengthen the cdu and make it more
effective one such measure is the
establishment of the bicycle response
team which works in coordination with
cdu
we can now deploy 100 trained and
certified bike officers as well as eight
trained and certified officials to
complement the cdu operations
of course our first responders can't do
their job without the proper equipment
therefore we've reviewed all cdu
equipment and upgraded it extensively to
protect our officers and enhance our
ability for crowd control
our improvements have touched every
component of the u.s capitol police
department but few changes are as
dramatic as the ones that we've made to
the way we gather analyze share
use and disseminate intelligence
however improvements to the department's
lead intelligence component the
intelligence and interagency
coordination division began before
january 6th
the department recognized that the
iicd's decentralized structure had
created informational silos
the continued focus
on this has yielded significant
improvements including a nationwide
search for a permanent intelligence
director the department is in the final
stages of that process we should have
somebody on board in the coming weeks
the development of a united states
capitol police intelligence product that
is now shared with the intelligence
community
the issuance of a daily intelligence
report distributed to all officers and
officials within the department
a bi-weekly classified intelligence
briefing
coordination with intelligence and law
enforcement partners in advance of large
or high-profile events
the realignment of task force officers
to enhance intelligence sharing and
dissemination
and the authorization for increased
staffing in fact we've added nine new
intelligence analysts
we continue to be forward-looking in our
efforts to ensure that the department
has a strong and proven intelligence
collection analysis and dissemination
program
i want to thank the committee for its
ongoing support during this process in
particular your support for the capitol
police emergency act
i also acknowledge and appreciate the
support that we have received from the
capitol police board
today i'm confident that the u.s capitol
police department has made significant
progress addressing the deficiencies
that impacted the department's response
on january 6th and while more work
remains to be done the men and women of
the capitol police stand ready to
fulfill their mission each and every day
thank you very much chief i want to
start by asking do you believe that the
department would be better able to
defend against the type of threat that
we saw
a year ago today than the department was
back then
yes absolutely thank you and we had
a number of recommendations i'm not
going to go through them all but i know
having reviewed your testimony having
our staff has spent significant time uh
working uh with your leadership
and uh that you are making progress to
implement the recommendations that are
pertaining to
the police department is that right that
is correct yes okay um as you know we
had the inspector general and senator
blunt and i had the inspector general in
um about a month ago or so and he also
issued more than 100 recommendations
which we truly appreciated
and uh he
talked about the progress that he knew
of that you had made at the time and
we've of course after that hearing as is
our job encouraged you uh to work with
him and to
report back on the progress can you tell
me uh where you are in responding to
this and the progress you've made on his
recommendations yes um
so at the time uh when the inspector
general testified i think we had about
30 of the rec of the 103 recommendations
that were closed that were implemented
that we had finished
at the time we also had another 60
recommendations that were basically in
progress that we had a detailed plan um
in place but the plan had not been
completed in some cases uh the plan
won't be completed until the fy 23
budget is is approved so some of these
it's going to take time but the plans in
place the the work is in progress so we
had we had basically addressed over 90
of the 103 recommendations we still
continue to work on those we have since
um i think closed another five or six
of the recommendations um we continue to
work on all of them and in fact we have
um i've assigned an inspector um
uh to work full-time uh for the next
several months to look at the the
recommendations that are not completed
and to see what we need to do to
complete them thank you thank you we've
got uh we've got a plan in place to
address all of them and you understand
we are very laser-focused here um
senator blunt and myself and the rest of
our committee on that accountability
given what happened
and so we appreciate that i'm sure we'll
have the inspector general back
next year and we'll continue this review
our report found that 75 percent of the
officers 900 of 1200 on duty on january
6 were forced to defend the capital in
their regular uniforms
many officers could not access riot
shields because they were actually
locked on a bus
the emergency funding legislation signed
into law in july included significant
new funding to improve capitol police
officers equipment access to equipment
do the officers now have better access
to equipment they need to do their jobs
and this is something individual
officers have spoken to me about as well
so we have um uh we've gotten shields um
uh for uh new shields because some of
the ones that we'd had were past their
expiration date um
the uh
and we deploy those shields every day in
fact i'm sure that as you walk around
the campus there's times when you pass
through a door and you notice that
there's a
stack of shields behind the door um so
we've got them deployed around the
campus in case we need them
we've ordered all new uh
equipment for our civil disturbance unit
officers that equipment like many things
is impacted by the supply chain issues
that are going on we should have that my
hope is
that this month but certainly in the in
the coming weeks we should have that
equipment that will be deployed but i
think the
the important part of of your question
is that any officer that uh would be
deployed as a cdu officer
now would have all their equipment it
might not may not be new equipment but
they will they will not come out there
without everything they need so we've
got new equipment on order we're gonna
uh it's upgraded it's better um and we
will be deploying that as soon as it
comes in and again hopefully in the next
few weeks um but we will send no other
no officer out to work cdu without all
the equipment that they do okay and you
mean civil disturbance unit there for
people watching correct for cdu
um and um no more locked buses where
they can't access it that was an
unbelievable story just horrific they're
looking at the equipment and they can't
get it
that would not happen again okay
um we all remember as i noted in the
opening the haunting words of the
officer does anyone have a plan as you
note in recent months the department has
made clear progress with respect to
operational planning in your testimony
you called this
game changer the fact that you have this
department-wide incident assessment plan
can you briefly expand on what has been
done to improve preparedness for large
events i know you noted you
hired someone who has key experience
with that anything else you want to add
so
we have an instant action plan uh
prepared for tomorrow uh for the
anniversary of january 6th this is a
copy of it's 25 pages long in it um
there everybody's responsibilities are
laid out this information is shared with
everyone so that a captain who's in
charge of one division
knows exactly what's going on in the
other divisions as well as his or her
own so
we are sharing information better we are
signing responsibilities people know
what their responsibilities are they and
we have backups to each one of the the
different commanders so the blueprint
that has been created um is
has we've
used it many times since the sixth and
we're very confident that it gives us
everything we need to ensure that the
planning that we do the sharing of
information and that everybody on the
department um understands what their
responsibilities are
as i noted senator blunt in my
legislation which was importantly
co-sponsored by many members of this
committee
gave you um and in general the capitol
police chief authority to request
assistance from the national guard in an
emergency
it was cloudy at best before and very
difficult
procedure how will this improve your
ability to respond in potential future
emergencies at the capitol well clearly
it it cuts through the red tape and
allows
allows the capitol police chief to make
that call directly um i have spoke with
the department of defense and in fact
i'm meeting with them later today and uh
to make sure that we have the the
process down um so that uh if that if
the time ever came that we needed to
make that call um every everyone would
know what the expectations are on on
both sides of the the call uh so uh that
is very helpful but i will just say this
that
um
my hope is that with the with the other
processes planning that we put into
place that there's not going to be the
need for a panicked call for uh in an
emergency that those things will be
planned ahead of time so that um
the uh
we'll have better coordination in
advance okay
uh you know we all speak to officers uh
in the uh capital and if my colleagues i
know they do and thank them every single
day um and one of the things uh that we
know is that many of them have been had
their vacations canceled they have been
working significant over time and i
think sometimes that's by choice and
right now
we are down officers and this was
something that was happening all across
the country honestly it's happening
right now but it's something that you
are uniquely challenged to deal with i
know there's more than 400 officers
short
could you tell us your plans to change
that
i have short-term plans and longer-term
strategies as well i think the the
important long-term strategy is that we
intend to hire over 280 police officers
in this fiscal year
in a normal year we would hire less than
half of that but because we want to get
ahead of attrition attrition that has
increased over the last year we're going
to hire 280 officers this year our
intent
is to hire 280 police officers for the
next three years uh that will get us
head of attrition and my hope is that
will get us to where we need to be in
terms of staffing shorter term
strategies are to look at hiring um uh
to re-employ annuitants hiring uh uh
or allowing for lateral transfers
lateral hires from other agencies and
then also looking at contract security
officers that can assist at at
particular locations where we don't
really need an armed capital police
officer and we're hoping that that would
free up um uh officers to be held over
less uh frequently to be able to you
know get their days off as they plan and
um address some of the the staffing
issues that are really impacting uh the
morale of this department thank you and
your long-term plan those to hire actual
officers
correct okay thank you
um last thing i mentioned the threats
against congress
many people in this very room committee
members have experienced them
over 9 000 threats
in 2021 alone that's an astounding
number
against 500 some people
and i understand that you've hired these
additional threat assessment agents
what steps are you taking uh to protect
members of congress and the people that
work with them
a better coordinate what we're trying to
do is um
have better coordination
we
can control and we can do a lot when uh
members are on campus um when they go
home when they go home their home
districts we're trying to work with the
local officers
in those jurisdictions to ensure the
safety and security of staff there of
offices there
and so we can provide
advice and provide recommendations in
terms of how to better secure locations
whether offices or homes
but we can also work more closely with
the local
law enforcement partners um to solicit
their help
the the biggest challenge i think we
have is keeping up with the number of
threats i mean we we have we've doubled
the number of
officers that investigate these threats
agents that investigate these threats
and
if they continue to go up the way they
have
clearly we're going to need additional
officers to assign to this
responsibility okay thank you chief
senator blunt
thank you chair
um the chief on the issue of bringing in
contract employees
um
officer papathonacio uh has suggested
that
the union the union rep that this would
be a problem for them do you want to
talk about how you're going to going to
deal with that obviously in my view a
bigger problem for them
is the overwork and the
extended stress of of being short so
many officers but
tell me how you plan to
work with the officers who are concerned
about bringing in
non-sworn officers to do
even parts of this work
so i i've been in uh
discussions with the union about this
specific issue
they have
mentioned a number of concerns and our
conversations uh and and our intent is
to try and address those concerns um
because i think where we vote what we
agree on is that these officers need
some relief that we need to to allow
these officers to get more time off to
stop being held over on their shifts to
stop being forced to work um uh over
time when they when they would rather be
home with their families so we again
i've talked about the strategies that we
have in place but this the the contract
security would be a temporary solution
um until we can get more officers hired
um and my intent is to try and address
the concerns that the union has with
regard to uh
where these contract security officers
are assigned and for that program to
really work what kind of what kind of
temporary program would it be would you
anticipate a
a
multi-year bid or a one-year bid with
possible extensions or what are you what
are you thinking about as you begin to
think about how you look for these
contract employees so i i look
realistically i think it's going to take
us
at least two to three years to get up to
our staffing in terms of hiring new
officers so
having that as as a an option to use
over the next
two or three years um i would like to
have that option just be sure we're
straight on this
um
hiring the officers to get to the
officers you currently are allowed to
have
is the the problem here as opposed to
the congress saying we're going to give
you 100 more officers than you're
currently capped at that's an
unrealistic
moment for us to think about your your
goal is to fill the slots that you
already
have been allowed to have and you're 400
short are you 400 short right now of
meeting that number yeah actually 457
short 457 yes sir
um
if i understood your thought also of
hiring 280 new officers a year for the
next three years understanding that
other officers will retire and find
other opportunities and you i that
number sounds about right to me to get
up to
where you need to be
how long is the training process from
the time you
bring an officer into the training
environment until you you have them
available for service it from the time
they're hired to the time you can
actually deploy them by themselves is
close to a year close to a year
so
hiring people annuitants who have
retired but are willing to come back to
work is one of your thoughts
that's correct because you'd be hiring
back someone who has that experience and
they could they could go back to work
day one and when you hire laterally
would you just uh
would you just and try to evaluate the
level of training that officer already
has and then determine what additional
training is necessary before you put
them into the line exactly yes
all right
um
the uh i think every police force in
america certainly every
big police force in america
has
a lot of that same challenge of just
people leaving
either the big force for a smaller
force in some
some other community or leaving with
frustration this whole idea that somehow
defunding the police was
uh ever any real option for
the country the inspector general's
testified before us that uh
he he thinks that in his view
restructuring
to where the
u.s capitol police
was more of a protective agency
instead of a law enforcement agency i'm
not absolutely sure
i know what he means by that
but why don't you give us your sense of
what after six months on the job
what's your vision of what the capitol
police force would look like
two years from now and five years from
now and maybe even longer if you've
thought through
the the the way that this force should
function to best do its job
well thank you for for asking that
question i i i
first i i
i think that uh where where i agree with
the inspector general is the fact that
we need to expand and enhance our
ability to investigate threats against
congress to provide protection to
members against congress
to
our counter-surveillance activities to
enhance security in the home districts
as i've mentioned
and uh
so in that regard we need to expand
our protection capabilities
but we we make no mistake we continue to
have to be a police department as well
the difference between
the u.s capitol and
the white house
or the cia or
you know other other facilities
is that we are open to the public
someone can walk in off the street now
not now because of covet but someone
could walk in off the sidewalk come
through the doors and say i just like to
look around i want to walk around and
that so we deal with the public every
day we deal with demonstrations every
day we have
to respond to crimes
most days we are
handling demonstrations we're making
arrests um we're staffing posts we do
crowd control visitor control employee
screening crime prevention response to
calls for service crisis negotiations um
all of which are part of being a police
department so while i i agree that we
need to expand our protection
capabilities uh i don't think that we
can walk too far away from our police
responsibilities as well because they
will remain
so in answer to your question about
where i think we need to go
one of the ways that i believe that we
need to
expand our protection capabilities is to
take
this
uh the work that we do in terms of
investigating threats
take the uh the uh our intelligence
responsibilities and make those invest
investigatory and intelligence
responsibilities and create a new
bureau and have a new assistant chief
an additional assistant chief so you'd
have
i think where dignitary protection and
protection responsibilities have grown
that continues to grow
the need there the case the workload has
increased um uniformed services will
always likely be the largest uh bureau
that we have but looking at intelligence
and investigations and creating a new
bureau with its own assistant chief i
believe is the direction that we need to
go um this this then um
speaks directly to the ig's
recommendation that we to uh move toward
more of a protection focus because that
what this would allow the department to
do
thank you i'll have more questions later
if we have time for a second round thank
you chairman
thank you very much senator blunt
next up
virtually
is senator warner who is the chair of
the intelligence committee um also has
played a very important role uh in our
responses since january 6 and before
then to other threats to our
capital and our
democracy thank you senator warner
well thank you chair clubatorn uh first
of all let me
echo what i said that on our last
hearing um
i want to thank you and
ranking member blunt for the way that
you've uh conducted both
the initial investigation and how the
rules committee is has really stepped up
in terms of the assessment of making
sure we protect the capital on
on an ongoing basis so thank both of you
i also want to highlight the chief major
at least to see you uh remotely
we had the opportunity to work together
when i was governor and you were chief
in in fairfax and
people still talk about your appraisers
we went through
you may recall those challenging three
weeks plus of the sniper incidents that
uh
terrorize frankly the whole the whole
region um but i know you are the right
person for at this point critical moment
in
terms of the evolution
and direction of the capitol police i
want to pick up as as
chair klobuchar just indicated and um
senator blunt's line of questioning
about the structure i know you're about
to name uh this new deputy chief who
will be
uh take on that role of intelligence
could you expand that a little bit when
do you expect to name that individual
and also
talk to us about
you know
the intelligence functions of the
capitol police will they be
mostly receiving intelligence from other
entities rather than doing your own
intelligence work will you pursue uh if
there is
indication of some kind of organized
threat will you pursue that versus fbi
talk me through a little bit more of
the role and structure of this
intelligence unit yes sir the the um uh
first we we have uh
you may uh be aware that we did have uh
a civilian director of intelligence
um uh on january 6 that person uh left
um
in the weeks uh following uh the sixth
um so we've been doing a nationwide
search we've um we're making going to
make a final selection in the next
couple of weeks and my hope is that we
have someone in place shortly thereafter
we have a very competent acting director
in place now
the i think the changes that we've made
um uh in our uh the way we gather
share
um disseminate intelligence
uh the big
there's been a lot of changes but the
big thing is how we use intelligence
one of the the problems of course on the
sixth was that we had information and it
wasn't
acted upon and intelligence is the only
use that
real intelligence is is if it's
actionable and you can and it can
actually help you formulate your plan in
terms of how you're going to deal with
the situation so we have uh now which we
did not have on the sixth we have our
own intelligence analysts uh we put nine
new ones in in place in in the last uh
few months
um that have the same training as an fbi
analyst as a
as a homeland security analyst so
um we we're we're speaking their
language we're sharing information we've
got people embedded in the fbi embedded
with dhs um and so uh and we've got our
task force officers on different task
forces with the fbi so we're actually
now plugged in to all the places we need
to be plugged into but we are also doing
while we are still sharing information
and getting information from homeland
security fbi we're not just totally
dependent on them anymore we have our
own folks that are also
doing research and and doing our own
analysis so basically we have we're
we're
you know staying
connected to our partners um uh in in
the federal intelligence community but
we're not just passive recipients
anymore we are active in the
intelligence community and we're active
in terms of sharing our information and
making sure that uh all the information
that we get gets down to uh to our folks
both the officials and the officers
but chief that means you are
but the investigatory role
is not something
that capitol police is going to take on
that will still be um reliant upon the
fbi or dhs or other partners right so
you may have the analysts if there's an
active plot
uh
that the pursuit of those plotters
though would be
the fbi not the capital police is that
correct
um i
for the most part but i would say this
that when we get when we get information
about threats against congress um that's
a priority for us and so
uh we we will take those cases and we
will uh we'll run with them
occasionally the fbi
helps us with those cases occasionally
homeland security helps us with those
cases but
they have to prioritize things too our
priorities are always the ones that are
threats against congress so in some
regard we do
we in fact are taking the lead role on
some of these cases if they have to do
with threats against congress
one last question i know my time is
expiring but um
one of the things i think we've gotten
better but we still have
room to grow in terms of the
intelligence community's willingness
to share
information on a regular basis my hope
and can you speak to this for a moment
do you have interoperable
systems so that you don't have to re
relying upon an agency
a partner to kind of brief you in person
versus at least having some of your um
agents analysts at a clearance level
enough that they can real time get that
info that intelligence that may be being
uh looked at from the fbi or again some
other uh agency that may even have a
broader reach yes um we do i mean we're
we have daily intelligence briefings
with um our partners around the region
uh and as as i mentioned we are plugged
in to the fbi we've remained plugged
into homeland security we've remained um
uh partners with um everything that mpd
is doing and and and washington dc's
homeland security so um we we are
absolutely connected and are speaking
the same language and sharing
information on a daily basis with all
those uh partners
thank you thank you madam chair
uh senator leahy
thank you senator blount and i i want to
thank you and
chair global for the bipartisan way in
which you've held
it's really a very important series of
hearings about the
insurrection of january 6 and you know i
have enjoyed all these years of working
with both of you
chief i'm glad to see you here and i've
enjoyed our conversations we we've had i
i think back i'm beginning my 48th year
here in the senate but i look at january
6th of last year
i never thought i never thought i'd see
a day like that a violent mob
driven by the rhetoric and the lies
of a disgraceful former president of the
united states
they attacked our seat of government
they threaten not just the lives of the
senators who are here in this room
but a congressional staff
of capitol hill reporters
and
chief manger you know so well the
dedicated law enforcement
officers are sworn to protect the
capital the people who work here and
what they face
because i have here served here so long
i
have gotten to know most of these
officers over the years dedicated
hardworking people
both in uniform and in
plain clothes
in fact one of the officers who died i
first knew him
as a teenager
you know this hits home this is a
capital family
here
and
hundreds of these heroes helped protect
the capital still walk the
ground today they're vigilant in pouring
their oath to protect and serve i
certainly see it
as president pro tem of the senate
those who protect that office
but
some were no longer walking here
there's officers of the capitol police
in the washington dc metropolitan police
who gave their lives protected our lives
they can't be out of our thoughts or our
prayers
their
their sacrifices shouldn't be
papered over by those who want to
pretend nothing happened
chief you came out of retirement to take
on an immensely important job at really
an
unenviable time and i praise you for
doing that
i know that you sit before us as a
representative the force should lead as
the force is struggling today
with morale and with memories and with
shortages
uh you spoke as recently as this weekend
about the staffing shortages facing the
capitol police
last year the senate appropriations
committee released a legislative branch
bill for fiscal year 2022 to provide
many million dollars more that's
pending and i hope we can finally get
these appropriations bills for it
senator blunt has been very helpful on
the republican side in the
appropriations committee and strongly
supported
the
extra 100 million
that we put in the last bill but if
congress fails to reach an agreement to
pass
fy22 spending bills
if you're held to last year's spending
levels
how would this lack of increased funding
impact the capitol police ability to
protect
the capital
um
senator it would impact um
just about everything that we're trying
to do in terms of making and sustaining
uh improvements especially in the areas
of of intelligence threat analysis
dignitary protection um and and security
infrastructure uh it would it would we'd
have to suspend our health and wellness
initiatives that that we've started
and i but i think the biggest impact
would be our inability to
increase our staffing which is so
critical all we would be able to do is
just replace the people that left
we can't we can't survive and continue
um we have to increase our staffing um
as i talked about before but that and
that would be the biggest impact well i
i commend both those republicans the
democrats who joined with me last
last year to get the extra money
uh for the capitol police and i hope
that we can all come together at both
parties to get our appropriations goes
through this year so that you will have
the additional funding that we've
uh put in there
and
tell me how
how you
use
some of these additional resources which
would of course disappear if we get
stuck with a continuing resolution
so um uh first the retention bonus that
we were able to provide officers um i i
think was is going to really have a
great benefit
um uh over 90 percent of our uh
department signed uh an agreement to
stay
for another year um minimum for another
year this will definitely slow down the
attrition in the upcoming year so it'll
allow us hopefully as we hire more so
the retention bonus um was was one of
the ways that we would i think we're
able to use that to help um with our
staffing issues the hazard pay anybody
that was here on january 6 got
hazard pay
we got the new cdu equipment
cell phones for every police officer
one of the big issues was
officers were not getting intelligence
information they get intelligence
briefings every day on their cell phones
and operational information every day on
their cell phones
their training initiatives that we want
to get to
uh
replacing and
replenishing equipment
that was deployed you know deployed on
the sixth um we've been able to to do
that as well so that money's gone to
good use and has really put us in a much
better position than we were in well i
thank you chief tara thank you and
in a few minutes i'll open the uh
center for the day of my capacity as
president pro tem
but then i'm also going to be speaking
to a lot of senators
this week in both parties
let's get these funding bills through
certainly you're an example of
the apartment that needs them
chair thank you thank you very much
senator leahy and again we all
appreciate you and senator shelby's work
to make sure that this chief and his
officers have the resources that they
need thank you so much uh next up uh
someone who's been
incredibly active on this committee we
appreciate his work uh senator merkley
of oregon he's here thank you very much
uh madam chair and thank you chief
manager for your leadership and efforts
to implement the recommendations of the
rules committee and the homeland
security and government affairs
committee as well as recommendations
from the inspector general's office to
enhance security of our capital complex
i want to directly thank
the men and women
of the capitol police force for their
heroism on january 6th
their service and resiliency in the
aftermath of that very
dark hour
made a lot of progress in this
past year as this this hearing is is
highlighting
and there's challenges to commas that
are also a part of this this hearing and
i wanted to just touch on a couple of
those first i wanted to be clear about
the number of officers who are currently
on the force you had mentioned uh the
numbers were short but how many officers
are on the force currently
um
i i'm going to have to get back to you
with that number here's what i will i
can tell you though
over the past year
153 officers uh either retired or
resigned from the department we have 175
on any given day we have 175 officers
that are on some type of leave um many
of those are are out
due to covid
um and so basically we are
four hundred and uh
i may have said 457 is 447 senator um
short uh where we of where we need to be
so uh i would think that we're somewhere
between somewhere around 1700 um that we
have that week between 1600 and 1700 we
can actually um deploy at a at a post or
assigned to a
to a responsibility
thank you that really puts that into
context then uh both the the the
shortage uh and um also your desire to
hire i believe you proposed hire an
additional 280 officers this uh
coming
uh year
and um
uh do you see
apart from the issue of funding assuming
there's adequate funding is that a
feasible
objective to achieve
i believe it is it it'll be a challenge
there's no question i mean
hiring that many officers the the real
challenge is to make sure that you hire
the right officers that we're hiring
good uh good quality candidates um
we have a plan in place to get them
trained and that uh
to so that um uh
that because that's been the choke point
in the past is is actually getting them
through um the training and the the
national uh or the federal law
enforcement uh training center uh we've
got a plan to get all the officers
through training
and
i think some positive news is that so
far we've not had difficulty in getting
in recruiting people we're getting
plenty of people who are showing
interest and wanting to be a part of our
organization we're still very selective
about who we uh end up hiring but uh i
do believe it's realistic and we're
going to do everything we can to uh and
we've got a plan in place to get 280
folks on board great great no i'm glad
to hear that the inspector general mr
bolton made the recommendation that all
the the members should obtain and
maintain a security clearance you
mentioned that intelligence is coming
through to the officers on a daily basis
i know that that may not necessarily
mean security clearance rated
intelligence but is um
is that is that part do you feel like
that that is a recommendation that
should be
fulfilled that that each person obtained
a security clearance and if so
do we need to have some sort of way to
prioritize
those security clearances given that the
security clearance process is completely
backlogged right now
so um the answer to the second part of
the question is absolutely yes we would
have to have um some method to to get
those done and this is really where it
comes down i believe that
uh it certainly has that recommendation
has merit but i am concerned about the
fact that i'm trying to hire 280
officers um if that uh security
clearance process slows that slows the
hiring process down that's a concern to
me i do know that um there are we
already have many of our personnel that
have security clearances um and there's
certainly i can look at assignments and
say yes someone in a particular
assignment would need a security
clearance but i also think that as we
hire new officers not every single
officer
in every assignment um would actually
need a security clearance so while i
think long term i think we can look at
that uh in the short term i'm concerned
about it holding up a hiring process and
um
and and do we really you know actually
focusing on where we need the officers
that actually uh would require security
clearance
well no i absolutely agree it shouldn't
shouldn't be a requirement to get on
folks on board but as you get them on
board and you feel they need those those
clearances
uh please raise to us uh the the need to
be able to clear the path so that so
that those who need those clearances can
can get them to fulfill the full range
of of their potential contributions to
the force uh thank you very much thank
you
uh thank you very much uh senator
merkley and chief next up so a very
constructive member of this committee as
well
senator capito thank you for being here
thank you thank you madam chair and i
want to thank the chief
on behalf of a grateful uh
recipient of the service that you and
the u.s capitol police provide on this
campus and in uh in our districts in
many times to look at the security of
our own offices and our own
uh homes and sometimes i i want to uh
express our deep appreciation and grant
and gratitude so thank you and i hope
you'll pass that along i read through
your statement um
and i read a a news
a news clip i guess this morning
talking about um
the the scars that are remaining uh from
the capitol police from the january
sixth
uh
incident uh
terrible incident
um
how is the morale i mean how how many of
your of your officers have actually
uh asked for uh additional mental health
uh do you feel you have the capacities
for that i know you've increased that
uh where is your level of concern right
now a year later
one of the priorities we had was to make
sure we had programs in place to deal
with um not only just the daily stress
of the job but folks that were actually
who
have gone through traumatic incidents
who experienced that trauma so we have
instituted a robust peer support program
we've net we're in the process of hiring
i think we've already actually hired a
couple
trauma counselors
we've got
formal programs in place now um where so
that officers can seek that help uh i
can't tell you how many have have sought
that help because it's confidential and
because when they i was just looking for
a general bar well is there is there a
great take-up of this or i i think i
think that um a fair number of officers
have made them uh have availed
themselves to these services and i think
as they um hear from other officers how
much the
these programs have helped it may
encourage more officers to to seek that
help as well i you know i i i'm glad you
asked about the morale issue you know
morale for somebody's been a cop for
over 42 years um
morale's always uh what i've learned is
it's in the eye of the beholder um
you're always gonna have uh cops that
that um you know uh will tell you oh
morale's the worst it's ever been
but you have other cops that every day
they show up no matter what happens
they're happy to be there and love their
job um so it's really um
but
it what it comes down to is and i think
in in for us
is we need these officers need to
believe in their hearts that this
department cares about them that what
happened on january 6 where the
department let them down in so many ways
that the department um
will take responsibility for fixing the
those failures and for making sure that
that never happens again and that's
going to take time for some officers you
know they've seen some of the
improvements and i think that you know
they appreciate it but for other
officers perhaps a little more cynical
um
it's
perhaps they're going to wait till the
first time we're tested again and are we
ready for that test and so it's one of
my responsibilities to make sure we
restore that confidence um
you know for the officers in the
department
let me ask you this a lot of in the
retrospective that we've done in this
committee and other committees there
were it's on the intelligence side
questions as to
was social media
paid enough attention to you know in the
run-up to uh to january the 6th what
adjustments have you made in terms of
the coordination between you and other
agencies in terms of the social media
monitoring so this is one of the areas
where we are taking more responsibility
and we can focus on and we're not
we're not trying to find you know
fi worry about you know something that's
going on in a foreign country what we're
worried about and what we're paying
attention to is threats against congress
and threats against the capital uh that
can be that is our focus and um so while
you have other intelligence community uh
folks that are looking at anything and
everything uh we've got folks in place
now that are paying attention to those
kinds of threats those uh statements of
that that you know cause concern so
we've got folks that not only are
looking at that that are watching for
that but we are also then um
ensuring that if it's if it crosses that
line uh in terms of being a criminal a
crime you know what someone says in
social media that we follow up on that
with an investigation is that different
i mean has that changed over the last
year that's a new addition um yes we've
got more people that are doing that yeah
good well i think before the six i'm not
sure we had anybody doing it but we
certainly but we've got i think eight or
nine people in place now that are doing
that with more on the horizon uh our
biggest uh uh challenge right now is is
uh keeping up with the caseload in terms
of the threats against congress the ones
that cross that line where we do have to
do a criminal investigation
well thank you again and i know i did
want to ask about i know you've been
asked about the 400 openings that you uh
that you've talked about and the
recruitment and
um you know
i know that they're probably law
enforcement in general i don't know what
the what the female
ratio is but i'm sure it's quite low so
i i noticed that too in the capitol
police so i i'm hoping that you're
making special efforts to diversify the
workforce as you're as you've got this
opportunity
to hire more people
it's a great career and i'm certainly
grateful as i stated so thank you so
much thank you
thank you very much senator capito next
up
senator king who brings his strong sense
of independence to this committee and we
appreciate him as well senator
king i'm going to give senator king a
minute here
uh
i'm sorry
am i yeah now i'm on youtube you're all
good
okay thank you uh chief i hope you will
convey our
uh appreciation to the men and women of
the capitol police
whenever i'm interacting my sort of
standard comment is thanks for looking
after us
and that we really do appreciate it and
and uh in the day-to-day politics it's
hard sometimes for people to realize
that so please convey the
deep appreciation and thanks from from
all of us that we care about uh what
they do and we appreciate what they do
for us
a couple of couple of things you touched
on the issue of security clearances and
uh that's a problem throughout the
federal government although i must say
it's better now than it was two or three
years ago
one of the questions uh that has been uh
plagued us is reciprocity
do you have a situation where somebody
has a security clearance from another
federal agency but then when they come
to apply to you they have to start all
over again or do you have a reciprocity
arrangement where if they're cleared for
state or the fbi they're also clear for
the capitol police i i we um
if it's done by
um some either the department of defense
or the fbi
um
typically if it's if it's done uh by any
federal agency i would think that that
would um suffice for us
okay well i would urge you to look into
that because it sounds it doesn't make
much sense but believe it or not there
are plenty of places where that
reciprocity isn't honored and and it
really delays the process and as you say
you can have a good recruit
but they get discouraged by the length
of the security clearance process and go
on and find another opportunity and in
this economy we can't afford to lose
good people
a couple of other
questions and observations
in terms of of your planning it seems to
me that one of the things that we've
learned on january 6th is there was a
lack of of free planning in other words
a lack of imagination we have to have
people that are thinking the unthinkable
and saying okay what happens if what do
we do so i hope that's the case and my
question is do you feel that we have
adequate communication and coordination
with other agencies that might be
important either from an intelligence
point of view such as the fbi or or
the other intelligence agencies
or with law enforcement d.c metropolitan
police the national guard are there
are we working on pre-existing
coordination and communication plans so
that we don't have to make it up on the
fly in the case of an emergency the the
the answer that question is yes we are
um and in fact um it has become a part
of our
the blueprint that we use um in terms of
our pre-planning for these events um to
to reach out to those partner agencies
to ensure that we're sharing information
that
if we
plan we believe that we're going to need
their help that we uh uh plan for that
um
well ahead of time so that we're able to
do and we end up doing tabletop
exercises we end up getting the
commanders over here to show them
exactly where we need their folks
deployed and and what responsibilities
that we're going to give to them so
absolutely that's part of our planning
process now
and i hope that extends to the
intelligence side as well you mentioned
you're you're developing some of your
own intelligence capability but we have
as you know enormous intelligence
capabilities throughout the federal
government my concern is we still tend
to have silos uh they're excellent silos
but they're still silos uh and i hope
that that the
the uh the coordination includes
pre-event intelligence
it does and um and we you know one of
the problems that um we identified
shortly after the sixth was the fact
that we even internally we had um uh
intelligent silos within our
organization those are are gone and um
we with the uh the briefings that we
have with our partners uh multiple times
a week um any silos that that existed um
previously certainly do not now
final final question and i remember we
discussed this not you and i but this
was discussed in a prior hearing and
that is
work with the architect of the capitol
in terms of the physical
infrastructure and the
ability to seal the building
effectively
and again we're back to silos i hope
that there's a close relationship
between your department and the
architect of the capitol because
your job your people's job could be a
lot easier if we had lexan windows and
metal doors that could easily be closed
in the case of an emergency
you know one of the things that uh the
the architect has done is to make sure
he's hearing everybody's voice he's
brought experts in um to to
do reviews and and provide
recommendations but he's also ensured
that everybody has had been able to uh
um uh lend their voice to to their
concerns about physical physical
security so i think that um that's all
been part of his planning process
great well thank you very much chief and
thanks again for the for to all of your
people for the great work that they do
on our behalf thank you madam chair
thank you
thank you very much senator king and
next up
senator cruz thank you for being here
thank you madam chair
chief welcome morning
thank you for your service
and i want to start by by thanking the
heroic service of the men and women who
serve alongside you
we are approaching a solemn anniversary
this week
and it is an anniversary of a violent
terrorist attack on the capitol where we
saw the men and women of law enforcement
demonstrate incredible courage
incredible bravery
risk their lives
to defend the men and women who serve in
this capital
we are grateful for that courage we
appreciate
the selfless sacrifice
of the men and women who keep us safe
and and i will say
my view is that anyone
who commits an act of violence
should be prosecuted
and anyone who assaults a law
enforcement officer
should go to jail for a very long time
and i think that's a principle that is
true
regardless of the politics of the
violent criminal whether they are right
wing left wing or they got no wings at
all
if you assault a cop you ought to go to
jail for a long
long time
and i hope we get some agreement that
that should be true regardless of the
political context
that ostensibly and purportedly
justifies that violence
that that
we will stand with the men and women of
bloom so i thank you for your service i
thank thank the men and women who served
with you for their service thank you
as we reflect on what happened a year
ago
it is also worth asking as as we have as
this committee has as congress has as i
know you have uh what could have been
done differently
what could have prevented the breach of
the capital what could have prevented
uh the the riot getting as far as it did
uh and and so let me just start with
with that question with the benefit of
hindsight
uh what could have been done to better
secure the capital
uh to stop the riot outside and prevent
them from from penetrating as far as
they did so i think that um
clearly
documented intelligence failures um
there were leadership failures within
the capitol police department
if
folks had uh if if the intelligence had
been acted on the way it should have
been
um
and we would have had enough people here
um i think it would have been a
different story and that one of the
things that we have one of the changes
that we put into place
is that
with a few phone calls
i can get
double or triple the number of police
officers we have
trained
equipped police officers here to assist
us uh in our responsibilities to protect
the capital and protect the members of
congress so um
you know as as
and we will be tested again senator i
mean i i and i don't know who it's going
to be or when it's going to be but we
will likely be tested again but what
will be different is that we will be
um
paying much more attention to the
information that we gather ahead of time
we will be putting up together a better
plan we will be getting the help that we
need pre-planned here
on campus um
before we need it not
making panic calls later on and i'm and
i say that in not in any way criticize
the folks that were here on the six they
had a very difficult challenge and i'm
the la and i frankly have not been
looking
behind me i'm looking forward about what
we need to do to make the changes but
clearly when you look at the
recommendations when you look at what
happened
we were uh we didn't have the
people
we we didn't act on the intelligence and
we just weren't prepared the way we
should have been and that that's gonna
change that has changed and um and the
next time that we're tested um
we will not be making those same
mistakes
well and and let me say one of the
things we've seen the last two years is
is a dramatic increase in threats
directed to lawmakers and and those
threats
are bipartisan that directed at
republicans and democrats the chairwoman
and i have discussed this at length
and then let me say the capitol police
does a tremendous job
uh working to deal with those threats
and and working to to keep us safe we
are grateful for that
um
the two areas you identified for
improvement were intelligence gathering
and manpower
on the manpower side you talked about
the ability to surge additional
resources
what are the sources of those additional
officers to surge on the manpower side
and then let me ask secondly
on the intelligence side what more do we
need to do on the front end
to anticipate the specific threats that
we need to be ready for so in terms of
of um
surging staffing here
we've got
federal partners we've got state and
local partners we've got the national
guard
um all of all of whom uh we have uh
coordinated with
uh since the sixth all of whom we have
sat down and said okay when we need help
here's how we're going to do it one of
the things and i thank the um
both senate and the house for uh passing
the supplemental we have included there
was um
funding so that if we asked for
um state and local help and at one point
for one event we had uh an additional
400 500 police officers trained civil
disturbance unit police officers here um
to to enhance our capability
we were able to um offset the expenses
from those partners so that when we make
the request
we're going to get a yes um
metropolitan police department and chief
conte could not be we couldn't find a
better partner um than mpd uh i speak
with the chief fairly frequently um
he uh
and
anything that we need
um is
again the answer is yes from mpd but we
we know we need to talk ahead of time to
pla plan for these things which takes
takes to your second question about the
intelligence and what we're doing on the
front end um
we did not um
we
prior to the sex we were not sharing
information the way we should be
and we were not disseminating it to our
own people the way we should be
and
we the only um
intelligence is only useful if you if
you act on it um when you get
intelligence you need to
you need to say okay how does this
impact our operational plan what are we
going to do we know we've heard this we
have this intelligence we believe it's
credible what are we going to do about
it so
um
those those are changes with that we
have made and put into place so that we
are sharing it we're acting on it we're
using it we're uh and we're
disseminating it to our to our own
officers so um i
you know i we we're going to get tested
again and
but
we have put things into place to make
sure that
it we will not be impacted by
intelligence failures or failure to plan
ahead failure to imagine or failure to
um have enough people here those are
things that we've put into place that um
i'm confident
that uh
when we're tested again
we're going to be fine
thank you chief
thank you very much senator cruz thanks
for the focus on member security and
we'll continue to work together on that
next up is
senator padilla such a leader on voting
rights on this committee with his
past
work as secretary of state for the state
of california
thank you senator padilla for being on
today
well thank you madam chair uh before i
get to a couple questions that i want to
prioritize
i want to take the opportunity to uh
comment on something that senator cruz
just raised i mean i appreciate the fact
that he
recognized uh last january 6th i believe
he called it a right and referenced
rioters i believe it was an insurrection
personally we can discuss and debate
what the proper terminology is but even
if it was just
a right we saw the result
of that incident
we saw violent attempts
to disrupt congress
uh to disrupt the the process of
certifying the election results uh and
in
uh it's part of the greater peaceful
transfer of power we saw violence it was
deadly violence uh we saw attacks and
assaults far beyond intel's
towards capital police officers so if
we're in agreement on a bipartisan basis
to recognize january 6 for what it was
then we should also agree on a
bipartisan basis to ask some questions
was it organic and spontaneous or was it
organized and premeditated
if it was organized and premeditated
you're gonna have a hard time convincing
me otherwise that we have to ask the
questions who was behind it who
organized who incited this we had the
opportunity to set up an independent
bipartisan commission to answer those
very questions
but unfortunately our republican
colleagues would not uh vote to do so
and so now i and so many people across
the country eagerly await the results of
the committee that was established in
the house
a bipartisan committee uh which seeks to
answer some of these questions but uh uh
let me now transition back to some the
the topic at hand the issues at hand and
some of the questions that i was hoping
to raise uh uh first in the context of
this information uh chief um i thank you
for your service at this time of this
agency and for your more than 40 years
of working law enforcement the topic of
this information has been raised by some
of my colleagues already in this
committee i will not repeat them
but i do want to highlight one specific
uh question uh the role of
disinformation in the lead up to january
6 uh is one thing but what
has been done since
last year's insurrection is another and
i'm referring to the former president of
the united states uh and his political
ally seeking to whitewash in fact what
happened uh some quoted publicly
claiming that those who attacked the
capitol were just both peaceful
protesters and quote
perhaps nobody knows just how false
those claims are than the women and men
of the us capitol police who were beaten
and bloodied defending
the people inside this building and yes
defending democracy itself so chief what
do you say to those who continue to
perpetuate the lie that lasts january
6th
we are not concerned about
political ideology we're concerned about
behavior we're concerned about people
that break the law
and people break the law
there are extremists on both sides of
the spectrum that are breaking the law
and um we're here to protect the capital
protect the members of congress that's
our mission and i would say to anybody
that um wants to to
come to this capitol
and peacefully demonstrate we will we
will protect your right to do so but
anybody that comes here and decides they
want to break the law that we're going
to do everything in our power to stop
you and to ensure that um
that the capital and the members of
congress remain safe
all right chief i don't think i need a
follow-up question to that but
apparently i do do you think what we saw
in the capital last january 6 was just
another day just people exercising their
constitutional rights
or was it unacceptable
fatal
violence
as i watched um the events of january
6th i was i was at the time um retired i
was at the time watching it on tv and i
was horrified by what i saw i saw police
officers being assaulted
and um that's the reason i'm sitting
here today is because i wanted to do
what i could to to help this police
department and to um uh to better
protect uh our nation and and um the
capital and and the
um
and what this capital represents
thank you for that claire we have some
ongoing work to do well one other quick
question but i'm trying now my time is
up i want to recognize that senator
capital raised
the concern and the questions about the
mental health of the women and men of
the u.s capitol police i share in that
and stand by rather support any
additional resources or support that we
can offer i do have one question about
physical health
we know that
businesses organizations entities